[Música]
i
jordania es el primer país árabe y uno
de los primeros del mundo en vacunar a
la población refugiada contra la cob y
19 el reino hachemita acoge a cerca de
un millón entre refugiados solicitantes
de asilo y desplazados que recibirán
gratuitamente la vacuna ya que se trata
del sector más vulnerable de la
población desde que se detectó el primer
caso en el campamento desatar y hace un
año las autoridades jordanas han tomado
fuertes medidas de contención para que
no se propague el virus en los
campamentos y el resultado ha sido que
sólo el 1 como 6 de los refugiados ha
contraído el cob it a diferencia del 3%
del resto de la población aquí en el
líbano también se va a priorizar a los
refugiados palestinos para ser vacunados
mientras llega la vacuna que está
prevista a mediados de este mes y
mientras tanto la población seguirá bajo
estrictas medidas de confinamiento ante
el repunte de los casos de coronavirus
i
[Música]
con el programa de vacunación en turquía
y ya desde hace varias semanas ha
empezado y más de un millón de personas
han sido vacunadas existe sin embargo
una duda muy grande en el país turco y
es que pasará con los 36 millones de
refugiados sirios que actualmente viven
en este país el gobierno ha explicado si
van a ser vacunados si no o qué va a
pasar con ellos dentro del plan de
vacunación que hace poquito ha empezado
y sólo se han vacunado personas mayores
de 80 años y personal sanitario entre
ellos existe una duda muy importante
también existe en el norte de siria las
zonas controladas por turquía dentro de
siria y controladas por la oposición
como su gobierno no está reconocido por
naciones unidas no se sabe qué va a
pasar y se van a poder recibir vacunas y
el problema dicen muchos de los
refugiados que viven ahí ahora mismo
huyendo de la guerra es que el
coronavirus está completamente desbocado
en la región
[Música]
las autoridades colombianas continúan
recibiendo críticas por la gestión de la
vacunación de su población sin todavía
tener fechas claras para el inicio del
proceso de inmunización cuando el país
supera los 2 millones de contagios
además el pasado mes de diciembre el
presidente iván duque anunció que los
migrantes irregulares procedentes de
venezuela que constituyen más del 55 por
ciento de los casi 2 millones de
venezolanos que residen en colombia no
recibirán la inyección del suero contra
el coronavirus el mandatario colombiano
enfatizó que su prioridad será la
vacunación de las personas colombianas y
hasta el momento solo los migrantes en
condición regular están incluidos en el
plan nacional de vacunación bajo las
mismas consideraciones que la población
nacional tras la polémica duke pidió el
apoyo de la comunidad internacional para
la adquisición de vacunas para la
población migrante la exclusión de los
más vulnerables y la discriminación de
personas por su estatus migratorio
podría tener un alto costo para el país
desde el punto de vista epidemiológico
[Música]